will are you there yeah man how's it
going i'm doing well man i don't know if
you see this but i'm running solo today
hold it down all right will
people are freaking out all right people
are saying hey look bitcoin bitcoins
down from 69 we hit an all-time high
whatever seven to ten days ago uh it's
below 60. so just on a general before we
dig into the charts and the on-chain
analytics like where are you at from a
sentiment perspective
generally like twitter sentiment can can
be faded it's kind of plus ev
um yeah i mean right now twitter
sentiments absolute garbage you go on
there everyone's like depressed and
stuff and you zoom out and
you look and we're at you know
we're in the upper 50 k's and everyone's
panicking you know it's it's kind of
funny how you know you lose perspective
in that sense um you know we've been
pretty much up on lease in september
with no correction you know we get we
get our first correction since then and
all of a sudden everyone panic so you
know i think it's it's easy to kind of
uh you know lose sight of the the bigger
picture as well as kind of get caught up
in these kind of short-term fluctuations
which are all part of bitcoin you know
markets trade both ways you have to
trade up to trade down you have to trade
down to trade up um it's just part of
how markets move um and so you know i i
think
through what we'll get into in a second
you know i think um in my opinion the
the kind of broader thesis that we've
been talking about
of in the sense of being in a bull
market hasn't changed um and until we
start to see those those behavioral you
know trends and the data change i'm not
going to change my outlook either
um you know i kind of i kind of follow
the data
and you know see what it says and i try
to stay you know unemotional and
objective as possible
yeah i think that's the beauty of the
on-chain analytics right in the metrics
which is everyone just saying hey let's
remove the emotion from this let's look
at what the data says let's look at what
the numbers say so let's dig into it
let's look at uh the future perpetual
funding rate chart to start what's going
on there
yeah you mind if we just back up and
touch on this first chart really like
just the the top price chart um i just
want to point out something real quick
so first of all like um
what we had talked about about two weeks
ago was we are entering this volatility
squeeze which is highlighted by this
kind of yellow shaded area we are smack
dab in the middle of these two uh
bollinger bands which are essentially
looking at the standard deviation from
price
and what we said was that
in the last three squeezes we had we we
faked out in one direction to grab
liquidity from breakout traders before
reversing and so this actually happened
a fourth time um and so like as we were
kind of breaking out above that top band
i sent out a tweet and basically said is
it happening again um and of course
everyone was like no no no no we're
going to the moon
but you know it's like you you look and
see kind of patterns repeat
and so based off of that i was i was
kind of cautious as we broke above um
this upper bollinger band and we did in
fact get a fourth fake out uh
essentially of you know a fake a fake
fake out or break you know fake breakout
um you know to the upper side of the
bands before before reversing now to the
to the downside so it's just something i
wanted to point out um you know we we
were kind of watching for this
and you know just moving forward we'll
be watching for that again because this
has been a pattern that's now occurred
several times in a row where you kind of
have seen um you know whatever special
force that will that you want to call it
that's uh you know behind price uh kind
of leading leading into you know kind of
this this fake out to grab that
liquidity um everyone everyone's like
okay you know we're squeezing to the
upside and then you know reverse the
market and that and that's kind of what
we've seen um not to get like like into
like any kind of conspiracy theory and
say there's like the illuminati behind
the price but that's just generally how
markets trade is they move to where the
liquidity is um and so you know i'm not
i'm not fully surprised to see this move
that we've seen because we were we were
prepared for this um and and some of the
stuff we'll get into in a second um you
know we we've been kind of due for a
reset on some things like funding and
sober and and this is stuff that we've
talked about for a while so um you know
not not all not all surprising per se
so basically the way i read that chart
is if it breaks out to one way or the
other that at least the last three or
four times it has gone the other way and
it's basically like a pump fake or a
head fake and it goes the other way uh
which people were excited to see the
first time and then it went opposite
again right so uh that's the way to read
that chart and then we'll so let's move
on to uh the perpetual funding rate what
do you got here
yeah i think we talk about this every
week so funding is essentially based on
the premium or the delta which just
means the difference between um the mark
price so whatever the perp is trading at
on an exchange as well as kind of the
weighted spot the average spot price
which is called the index price so you
look at all the major spot exchanges and
give them kind of this weighted average
by volume
and so funding is essentially the
mechanism that pegs the perp to the
actual weighted spot price um and so
funding can have some signal because uh
you know it it's essentially tracking um
the the aggression of uh the perp
traders relative to the relative to spot
as we just mentioned um you know
generally speaking prolonged positive
funding is is kind of a
signal of caution although we can see
that occur for for longer than than
you'd expect like earlier this year we
had prolonged positive funding for two
or three months where funding really has
actionable signal in my opinion
is when we see price going one direction
meanwhile funding is going the opposite
and so this happened on tuesday of this
week we saw price was grinding down
meanwhile we had rising funding as you
can see right between uh 15 november
15th and november 16th on the bottom on
the bottom axis there
you'll see funding was rising as price
was grinding down um so you know that
wasn't all entire you know entirely
surprising to see us kind of get this
little wipeout but in general this move
has been more driven by spot um than
than uh like a leverage any kind of like
leverage wipeout
i think
since funding is kind of like been more
widespread in terms of knowledge on on
on twitter or whatever like platform uh
people generally now have been like
blaming uh like the leverage for every
single down move which isn't always the
case um oftentimes it's the case in the
short term um because we have you know
massive liquidity on these perpetual
swap exchanges and we have massive
leverage compared to anything in
traditional finance
but you know sometimes believe it or not
some people actually sell their bitcoin
and that's what we've seen over the last
couple days especially from uh biffin x
we've seen biff next trading at a
discount to several other major
exchanges um and so you know overall you
i think a lot of that selling pressure
has come from bitfinex but in general
you've just seen um you know heavy heavy
spot selling paired with some
liquidations
you know i think we saw like 125 million
dollars of liquidations of long
liquidations yesterday uh but yeah i
mean in general this is this the down
move just seems like um you know some
some profit taking since we haven't
really had any kind of major correction
um since we retested 40k
in september um and you know i mean it's
it's not just fully like a you know kind
of a leveraged liquidation kind of move
yeah well uh you can't introduce common
sense on twitter man don't try that all
right
and then all right so let's move to
sopra uh you got a bunch of analytics
here to sopra uh the family of metrics
let's start with the short term holder
one
yeah so it's for anybody who doesn't
know um so glass node identifies
short-term and long-term holders using
this 155-day threshold which is uh five
months reasoning is behind
they've done some statistical studies
which what they find is that over time
the longer a coin is held by an entity
uh the more likely or i'm sorry the less
likely it is to be spent uh but right at
that 155 day cut off that's where that
likelihood really kind of drops off the
most um and so what we're looking at
here is soper which is our spent output
profit ratio which looks at all the
profit and loss realized on any given
day but then we normalize it just
looking at the short term holders in
this case
and so what you can see is that first of
all well first of all you need to
identify what the broader market trend
is and and we do this through other
metrics that we've covered you know for
the last couple months
and a few of which we'll we'll touch on
later in the letter
but once we've identified that broader
trend we can use soper specifically this
short-term holder soaper in this case
to look at opportunities to a buy the
dip along one
and then in bearish trends fade the
rallies or underside tests of one and so
as you can see you know at
during during the end of last year
beginning of this year every time we
kind of came back down and retested that
one threshold those were good
opportunities to buy whenever we
slightly dipped below um and then as
well you know you could see over the
summer we were just in we were kind of
in this mini bear market phase and so
then we kind of had this prolonged
period where we stayed below and every
time we came back from the underside and
tried to retest that that was rejected
and so right now we've we've had a nice
little uh you know
move below one here and so you know
given that we think that we're in a
broader bullish trend which we've kind
of built a case for using other metrics
um you know if that if we do believe
that is the case well then you know this
this dip below one uh should present a
good uh buying opportunity and also
means that we're likely bottoming out if
we haven't already
yeah and so i think what's fascinating
is when you look at it on the seven day
average which is your next chart here we
already got confirmation of the bull
market uh a couple months ago or a month
ago what are you looking at now on the
seven-day moving average chart
right yeah like like you mentioned we
got confirmation at the end of september
um very similar actually to the end of
september of last year where we also got
confirmation and then just began
trending upwards um yeah i mean what i'm
looking for is are we going to come back
down and re-test that one threshold if
we do uh i'd happily buy there just
because given other metrics like i said
or showing that we're kind of in this
broader you know bull market structure
um you know i'm not i'm not betting that
we do get this reset just because it's
it's the weekly version so generally you
know you have to see a
a pretty significant move for us to come
back down and retest that
but it is nice to at least see us kind
of reset a bit and i wouldn't be
surprised for us to come back down and
and you know touch that touch that one
threshold again and get a second you
know uh second confirmation if you will
um but yeah i mean what you don't want
to see obviously is this to break below
one and then failed re-test from the
underside uh you know as we mentioned
but uh yeah i mean for now we're sitting
pretty close to one we've gotten a nice
little reset over the last you know call
it two three weeks
and so you know i mean even if even if
we don't come back and get that
confirmation which we already got at the
end of september you know i like that
we've gotten a bit of a reset here
and are you looking at kind of the same
thing on the next chart which is the
short term holder profit and loss of
just looking to see if we get reset if
we go towards one again and bounce off
yeah yeah same concept um you're just
looking at here instead of with sober
you're looking at all the spent outputs
you know in the definition spin output
profit ratio but here what we're looking
at is the just the aggregate state of
profit so if
instead of looking at the the coins that
are actively being spent or traded on a
given day you're just looking at okay
you know these guys are sitting in
profit unrealized profit and unrealized
loss and you're running the ratio of the
two of those things um so it's very
similar same concept in the sense that
you have this kind of one threshold that
you look for to kind of get confirmation
for you know whatever market trend that
that we're in
as well as you know when we get a break
below that you know that's that's a you
know bearish uh you know it's a bearish
break or when we break above this like a
bullish break um just like sober you
know if you're looking for the same
dynamics that you see in sober it's just
a different way of of uh you know
calculating it i guess all right cool so
then let's let's go to the on-chain uh
the on-chain cost basis right and maybe
just talk through kind of how this has
confirmed bull markets in the past and
what you're seeing here now
yeah so um so you can call this a couple
different things you call it the cost
basis or realized price or v-wop um and
so it's just you know it's all saying
the same thing so you're looking at a
v-wap is a volume weighted average price
you're looking at
realize cap which we've talked about
several times is the market
capitalization of bitcoin
based off of the last time that coin's
removed and so we can kind of track the
amount of capital inflow coming into the
market
and then we normalize this for just
looking at short-term holders in
specific um as as we mentioned we can we
can look at things based off of that but
cut off that glass node has 155 days to
look at short-term versus long-term
holders um and so what we see is that
like historically the short-term holder
cost basis or realized price or v-wap um
sorry i know i'm throwing like three
different things in there it's all
saying the same thing um they've all
kind of served as uh this is served as
kind of the support band in bull market
so if you go back and look at 2017 you
can see these like four different
retests where we came back down during a
correction and tested this and bounced
really nicely off of that
as well as once we broke below that um
in in you know at the end of 2017 that
would have been you know time to time to
be cautious and then once you had this
kind of failed uh retest from the
underside that would have been your your
confirmation that you know we've we've
kind of broken the trend um and so it's
it's you know similar to it's similar to
sober and a lot of things which what you
can look at is you know when you break
below
some people will say okay you know
that's enough that's enough signal for
me to to you know change my my market
outlook right because we we haven't
broken below this uh you know throughout
the entire bull market now we've clearly
broken trend um but some people who are
a bit more conservative look for okay do
we have confirmation and then they'll
base their opinion off of once we get
that you know failed underside retest
and but you know you would have if you
did that you know let's say you sold
based off of this you would have kind of
gotten out at the same price point you
just basically sold at the dead cat
instead of instead of you know as soon
as it broke i personally stand in the
camp of i would be looking for kind of
this failed underside re-test because i
think you know
kind of the the it's really difficult to
time the exact top
um you know you kind of had these kind
of red flags and caution signals that i
think you can you can be given but
the you know the last the the last week
or two of parabolic moves are where the
largest portion of that move are made um
and so it's really difficult to like
time that perfectly but where i do think
it's reasonable to kind of um to look
for an exit is is on that dead cat move
uh and so this is just one of the you
know example of that where you know we
we had that failed retest from the
underside of that band and then as we
headed into you know the 2018 uh bear
market we had like three failed retests
from the underside of that once we
finally broke above that's when we came
out of the bottom of the bear uh heading
into that mini 20 you know 2019 uh bull
market whatever you want to call this
there's a lot of that was driven by the
plus token ponzi where they were like
artificially locking up coins uh but
that's like that's a conversation for
another day uh but then we had this
failed once we broke below we had this
failed underside retest so that's where
you would have become cautious again
until we once again broke back above um
after march 2020 uh you know you can see
in in september of last year we once
again bounced off uh bounced off of this
uh and then broke below um heading into
may which would have you know would have
been time to to become cautious as well
and then recently we've bounced back
above this uh you know at the at the end
of september so um two things a you know
notice that we've gotten back above and
bounced off of this conversely to the
end of 2017 where we had a failed
underside retest
of that right so it's it's showing you
that you know at the end of 2017 those
confirmation we're hitting into a bear
market whereas here as we've retested uh
at the end of september showing that
we're confirmation that we're back in a
bullish trend uh and and notice too that
we have confluence of a couple things
that we that we keep talking about the
end of september confirmation at the end
of september notice there's several
metrics that are all kind of pointing to
that same that same concept um and
that's that's what i really look for you
know you can see one metric and say okay
you know this is telling you something
but
when you have three or four different
things all pointing to the same thing
through something that we call
confluence um you know that's that's
where you can really feel strong about
your opinion when you kind of see that
across the board
yeah so that's super helpful and and the
next chart you have i think is
interesting because when you look at uh
the short-term holders and the realized
price of the short-term holders compared
to the long-term holders it provides a
pretty symmetrical uh
view of like when you should start
accumulating and when you should be
cautious like how do you think about
this chart
yeah i mean one thing i just wanted to
touch on the last one i just completely
forgot to say was just it's at just so
people know right now it's at 53k um so
that's kind of my bear market floor i
think we can go below as 50 to 53k um
you know and still hold bull market
structure um and that also aligns with
the technical level as well as 53k is
the 1 trillion market cap threshold for
bitcoin so i think that's a really
important level for bitcoin to kind of
hold is that that 53k level you know we
could wick below but i i generally kind
of stand in the camp of as long as we're
closing daily closes above 53k i don't
really see anything to be concerned
about um but yeah so sorry to get into
this chart um you're looking at what we
just looked at which is the short term
holder realized price or cost basis and
then you're comparing that to the long
term holder realized price or cost basis
and so you get this really clean
oscillator where what you see is that
whenever the short-term holder realized
price oh you know overextends the
long-term holder aka when short-term
holders are kind of dominating the
market um you can kind of get these
these signals of caution or kind of
overheated signals for kind of the the
broader market structure so you see that
happen in you know the two 2013 double
pumps as well as uh in 2017 and then
conversely uh whenever whenever a
long-term holder realize price uh goes
below short term hold a realized price
that's a that's a good time to
accumulate because showing long-term
holders are dominating the market the
speculators are leaving um and so as you
can see whenever we kind of cross below
that kind of green area that i
highlighted uh that that's a good time
to kind of average in buys we're sitting
in kind of this funky spot right where
we're not we're very close to the very
close to the accumulation zone never
quite uh you know tapped that as well as
we never really reached the overheated
zone earlier this year
and this is kind of a similar signature
to 2013 you know i think completely
different market structure to 2013 but
just in the sense that you know we kind
of had this parabolic advance came back
down
almost fully reset that and then kind of
reversed
so that's why that's what i highlighted
with those two blue circles uh but do
note though it only took three months
for for this oscillator to go from that
kind of reset between the 2013 double
pumps uh to coming back above that
overheated zone so you know this this
can happen quicker quicker than than
perhaps that uh you know you you'd
expect but for now we're sitting in uh
healthy territory and we're far from
overheated in that sense and it looks
like we've turned the the corner back
towards kind of where we're headed
towards that caution area or at least
you know a fraction of it do you think
that we could go lower right because it
looks like it's already made that cut
back towards that other zone do you
think that we could go further over the
next two three weeks
i mean anything is possible but you know
i think um i think it would take a lot
to you know this looks at like the real
macro kind of trend if you will or
broader trend so it's going to take a
lot to kind of see any kind of reversal
on this um i i generally kind of stand
in the camp that will probably just see
this start to start to tick up into the
future yeah gotcha okay all right so
let's move on to uh mvrv z score that's
a mouthful right there but tell me what
you're seeing here
sure so you know this is once again uh
looking at realized price so
you can't tell realize price is a really
important metric to kind of grasp and if
you're trying to get into on chain um it
was originally conceptualized by pierre
richard he's like a bitcoin og uh wrote
about like the speculative attack on the
dollar before that was even you know a
thing you know now now michael saylor's
actually doing that in real time but you
know pierre wrote this back in like the
very early days of bitcoin so you know
he's kind of a visionary thought of
thought of this concept uh nick carter
actually put it into action uh and then
presented it at this conference
at that conference uh david puel and
murad mahmudaf uh both saw it and and
thought of the idea to kind of compare
um the the realized price to market uh
to the market price to kind of get this
nice oscillator kind of macro oscillator
and then this this on-chain analyst all
in wonder um he he z-scored it which
essentially means that you're adjusting
it for volatility and that's what that's
what we're looking at here so we're
looking at the ratio of market cap to
realized cap and then the z scored aka
the volatility adjusted version of it
and so once again like
very similar to the last chart we looked
at but instead uh
you're instead of comparing the short
term holder to long-term hold of
realized price you're comparing just the
overall realized price to the market
price
and so what this is essentially trying
to capture is like
when the speculative bid or you know the
the you know uh
uh greed in the market the the
speculative market participants are
coming in and aggressively bidding the
the price of bitcoin up
relative to the amount of
capital inflows that are actually
supporting that right so that so so
market price is that speculative bid i'm
talking about versus realized price is
the actual capital that's coming into
the network
and so yeah whenever whenever you see
the speculative bid kind of overshoot
that when that's basically showing you a
really strong over exuberance or you
know the market is overheated uh we
break above this kind of red zone at the
top we kind of tapped into it earlier
this year never really broke above it
and had this kind of euphoric signature
that we've had historically and we had a
really nice reset um over the summer and
we're kind of just chopping around in
the middle
on the on the lower half but you know
kind of smack dab in the middle there um
and so you know as long as as long as
we're not you know kind of in this
overheated zone i think this you know
especially given that we're below the
the upper half of of you know if you
were going to cut this chart right down
the middle i think we're kind of still
in this kind of healthy area where we're
still far from from overheated if you
will
gotcha so essentially the capital
inflows are still supporting the price
of bitcoin that's kind of the t td tl dr
yeah i appreciate the full explanation
too
so let's go to the liquid supply shock
uh chart you have here i think the thing
that's fascinating about this is you
talk about it in your email which is hey
if it declines for a couple weeks in a
row a steep decline that's kind of a
reason to be cautious and we saw that in
2017 and then we saw that earlier at the
peak of this uh this bull market earlier
this year what are you seeing here and
what has it done over the last few weeks
yeah exactly so i created this metric
back in uh summer with willy woo so
you're essentially just comparing the
highly liquid and liquid guys to the
illiquid guys um so highly liquid guys
let's say they take in four coins they
hold only one out of those four so they
they hold only 25 percent of the coins
they take in uh liquid guys 50 50. so
they take in half spend half the coins
they take in and then illiquid they take
in and hold at least 75 percent of the
coins they take in so for every four
coins they take and they hold at least
three so you're running the ratio of the
highly liquid and liquid guys to liquid
to the illiquid guys essentially what
this is is the for in layman's terms
you're running a ratio of the weak to
strong hands to kind of get this what i
call supply shock
oscillator so you're tracking where you
know supply moving to these entities
that historically have a high uh
behavior of selling or are they moving
to entities that have a low behavior of
selling or history of selling
and so what you see is in bull markets
this this trends upwards as supply is
getting locked up in bear markets uh
this trends downward as supply is
becoming liquid
and so like you said this is kind of a
leading indicator in two ways
so a uh you know over the summer this
was a this was probably the the main
metric that i kind of used to to call
the reversal over the summer if you will
um
and so like we had this divergence where
this was turning up meanwhile price was
grinding down so you had like these
long-term holders with with low uh you
know history of selling they were
locking up supply and and you know
getting in the market buying actively
buying coins meanwhile price was
grinding down and so then once that
resolved we had this large kind of
supply shock effect in the market where
we had 10 straight up days off of the
lows
um and so that you know this is kind of
a leading indicator
as well as i didn't have this metric
back at the beginning of may also i got
into on chain analytics like two weeks
before the pico top which was great
timing um but you know if if we were
looking back that looking at this back
then which you would have seen is a
decline in this for about a week or two
before we before we had that major
correction on may 19th as well as if you
go back in 2017 um if you if you kind of
zoom in you'll see that there's a clear
decline in this in the week or two
leading up to that decline heading into
the into the bear market so we're right
now at 2021 all-time highs and you can
see recently we've had this really large
leg up which means that strong hands are
currently buying this dip um and and you
know we're at the highest that the
oscillator has been um since 2017 but
what we'll look what we'll be looking
for to kind of become cautious is uh you
know once once this starts to decline as
well as last week we looked at the rsi
of this so i took this kind of a step
further and created like a 60-day rsi um
and and what you see like
is is is you
in like 2017 we had this bearish
divergence between this so essentially
like the momentum of supply shocks was
slowing down as price was grinding up
and you saw the same thing at the
beginning of this year that we had this
bearish divergence between the rsi which
i put in the last newsletter if anyone
wants to see what that looks like um
you know we had this bearish divergence
between that and and price so
once once we start to see that bare div
as well in the rsi that's that's just
another way to kind of utilize this
metric to kind of
signal when to become cautious um and i
think you can make an argument as well
in 2017 that in in and not the rsi but
just in this in the in the version we're
looking at here that you had a bear div
where like the the oscillator made a
lower high compared to like if you look
like january 2017 versus like january
2018 we made a lower high versus now as
i mentioned we're reaching 2021 all-time
highs so we've actually you know made a
higher high in that so
i mean that's at least a good sign that
we aren't seeing a bear div in that but
um yeah those are some of the things
i'll be looking forward um so a to see
like a week or two decline in this as
well as in the rsi version of this i'm
starting to see that like bear div kind
of for me
yeah so the the next chart you have is a
long term holders net position i know
this is something that you watch uh a
lot right this is something that you
constantly talk about just talk us
through the idea of uh long-term holders
buying into weakness and selling into
strength because i think that initially
confuses a lot of people
um yeah yeah um so it's kind of
counter-intuitive
so you know when whenever you see red
generally you think red is bad right
humans just like red bad green good
right yeah uh but in in terms of in
terms of this metric um it's it's
actually kind of the opposite
because long-term holders are kind of
the smart money in the market so they
kind of buy into weakness they don't
perfectly you know buy the absolute pico
bottom but they scale into weakness and
they scale out into strength and so you
see this this behavior between long-term
and short-term holders throughout all of
bitcoin's history throughout every
single major rally in bitcoin's history
long-term holders have sold meanwhile
short-term speculators have come in and
bought their bags the whole way up and
then heading back into the bear market
you see a the short-term holders leave
or they age into long-term holders which
by definition is going to decrease the
short-term holder supply as they then
age into the long-term holder supply
and so when we're like i said when we're
in bearish trends let me start i'm sorry
when we're in bullish trends you start
to see those long-term guys begin
scaling out into strength as you can see
on the left-hand side of the chart they
started scaling out in october 2020
which was obviously far from the top but
it was just that was just the beginning
of the distribution right and we saw
them kind of peek out their spending in
january or january earlier this year
and then them starting to accumulate uh
at the you know kind of in april that
was actually kind of a bearish signal
because generally you know these are the
these are the smarter market
participants in bitcoin so they're they
know that weakness is coming so they you
know them starting to kind of scale back
in it's kind of actually a caution sign
although it's kind of counterintuitive
uh because that's that's the trend that
you see throughout bitcoin's history
now recently over the last two weeks
we've started to see some red prints
which means that they've now started to
distribute again so you know this isn't
meaning that
the bull market is over like i remember
when i posted this there's a lot of
confusion about that which just means
that like the distribution has begun
this is natural bull market behavior um
and and you know where we'll start to
become cautious is where we have like a
massive distribution print like we had
in january of this year but right now
we're just in that same territory
territory that we were in like november
of last year coincidentally since
november but uh not that the timing
necessarily matters just the the trend
matters that we've we've just started
this distribution as you can see on the
left comparing to where we are now so i
have a couple questions real quick one
it seems like that's a leading indicator
by at least a few months is that correct
yeah i i would say that yeah okay cool
and then uh two my second question would
be like is there any evidence or what
are you going to be watching to see how
long that distribution can last for
right because i think people would be
curious of hey is that selling going to
be occurring for a month two months
three months four months or does it
really just depend on kind of what
market structure we're in
yeah like
this is something that we've we've
talked about like i feel like every
couple weeks where
i don't i don't think necessarily
looking at the market in the sense of
timing is useful and saying the market
is going to peak out in december or the
market is going to peak out at this
price
what i look for as an on-chain analyst
specifically you know there's other
forms of analysis you can do but just at
being you know solely from an on-chain
perspective what you want to look for is
just these behaviors and so you know
tomorrow we could see all of a sudden i
highly highly highly doubt this but we
could see all of a sudden a massive
distribution print like we saw in
january right and it just it just
depends on on um you know what we see
from from these uh market participants
and i just tracked the behavior so it's
like we know what what behaviors to look
for when those happen it's hard to say
we can kind of get a gauge as to
generally this kind of plays out over
two to three months right generally when
you start to see these certain supply
dynamics that we've seen since summer
that usually means we have continued
price appreciation over the coming
months uh but that's not to say that you
know those things could all of a sudden
occur in a matter of weeks so
what i'm trying to say here is
look for and just for listeners look for
uh you know look for
behaviors rather than time
and so you know just continue to monitor
this stuff and i will and if you don't
want to get a glass node subscription
and you know i'll send it out in the
newsletter every week and watch it for
you but you know watch the behaviors
rather than the timing um because
because the behaviors don't necessarily
have to have to occur in a specific
amount of time although perhaps we can
kind of get a rough estimate as to how
long they've taken historically
gotcha all right that's helpful thank
you uh let's check out the last chart
which is dormancy flow what's going on
here
yeah so so similarly uh above we looked
at the long-term holder supply and so
kind of on a similar note to that we
have other on-chain metrics that kind of
look at the lifespan of coins that are
being spent so we have coin days
destroyed um which are looking at you
know if you move a coin to a wallet
stays there for 10 days you have 10 coin
days being created you then move that
coin out of that wallet well now 10 coin
days are being destroyed
and then just for some people that may
say well what if i move a coin to
another address right
that's where glass node's entity
adjusted version really comes into play
because then you then you aren't subject
to those to those movements as well
but
also you can look at
the average spent output lifespan which
is the average age of coins of spent
volume age bands which is looking at the
amount of volume coming from different
age cohorts that's being spent on every
given day
and in this case we're looking at
dormancy these are all things i'm just
trying to make the point that these are
all different ways that you can look at
kind of these lifespan behaviors
and so dormancy is looking at coinbase
destroyed which we just described and
then it's adjusting it for uh volume so
essentially you're just getting the raw
uh the raw amount of dormancy uh that
that you know that that's taking place
or destruction that's taking place
and then what we look at here is we're
dividing uh we're comparing the market
cap to the usd value of the
usd annualized value of dormancy so
we're looking at dormancy multiplying
that by price and then looking at that
times 365 and then we're comparing that
to market cap so essentially we're
getting this oscillator of like kind of
this uh broader behavior of how you know
what what's what's this the trend of
spending from older coins in the market
uh and and what we kind of see is that
this this kind of uh black line that we
have here that that threshold has kind
of been a an a really interesting kind
of level that this is historically
interacted with you see like in 2013
we broke below that at the end of 2013
we broke back above the line in 26
heading into 2016 that was confirmation
we were coming out of the bear market
this served as support um in the 2017
bull run once we broke below that was
confirmation we kind of had broken bull
market structure
we bounced off of this in 2019 during
that mini bull run as well as earlier
this year
and then as well you see at the bottom
we kind of had this green area where
that's generally been a good time to
kind of accumulate or scale in some buys
um at the bottom of the bear um so we
kind of got this bounce just above that
that threshold where you know it was a
great time to accumulate historically we
got to bounce right above that over
summer and now we're just kind of
hovering in this kind of neutral area
where we're we're not quite fully at the
bottom so like the asymmetry isn't quite
you know
really isn't isn't insanely skewed but
it's i think it's still there in the
sense that you still have a lot of
runway to go before you kind of approach
this kind of uh overheated area uh
whether you want to say that that's at
the black line or above which which
occurred in 2013 2017 but even if you
want to make the argument that okay well
we topped out in 2019 and earlier this
year at the black line we're still we're
still you know below halfway between
that and the accumulation zone so no
matter how you want to kind of dice it
up we're still kind of far from this
exuberant signature or overheated level
if you will
gotcha all right will so uh i know i
really appreciate everyone in the chat
certainly appreciate you coming on here
every week dropping bombs dropping
knowledge uh it's amazing but if you had
these charts are super helpful right but
if you had to just zoom out for a second
knowing everything you know uh from an
on-chain analytics perspective and give
like a two-minute summary or a minute
summary of where you think the market
structure is right now and what it'll be
over the next few months like what is
your general take or your general
analysis on this
yeah so um
you know
in general i think we're still in a bull
market
and what we're watching for is all these
different behaviors you know go on my
look on my twitter account
not to show my twitter but look at the
pin thread i have like 20 different
tweets on there
in that thread that are all looking at
all these kind of macro behaviors to
look for moving forward um but in
general i think we're far from
overheated the timing exactly of when
the bull market ends i mean who knows i
mean i'm not going to sit up here and
lie and say that i know and you know i
think a lot of people have said that the
bull market's going to end in december
just because it's historically ended i
think there's a really strong case to be
made that we kind of extend out into
into the spring of next year but you
know as long as as long as these
behaviors that we've historically been
been watching um are far from that kind
of exuberant signature um you know i
think we're still in a bull market what
we're currently in my opinion is just a
correction that we historically have
seen during all you know bull trends and
bitcoin volatility is part of bitcoin um
you know you you essentially get paid
for the risk that you take on through
volatility um you know for for for
there's two sides of the same coin is is
risk and reward right you know the risk
being the volatility in this sense um
and so i i look at this as just another
buy opportunity i've been scaling in
buys not financial advice
since since we got under 60k i think we
could go as low as 53k on a daily close
but you know i'm not gonna i'm not going
to sit up here and say i know exactly
when the bottom is and why
um but you know i i've been scaling in
my eyes and i think i think we're still
in you know favorable territory in terms
of this is likely just a correction in a
broader kind of bull market that that
you know i've been kind of
trying to trying to illustrate uh for
the last couple months uh since summer
so
uh yeah i mean i kind of stand in the in
the same camp that i that i have um i'm
not i'm not concerned i see a lot of
people getting really concerned like the
fear the fear grade index is like pretty
deep in the fear zone now um which is
great because that's that's you know you
want to be buying the blood you want to
be buying when everyone else is freaking
out so
you know i would just say for like any
people listening you know just follow
the data right um you know if if the
data isn't telling you to be worried
then don't be worried if the data is
telling you to be worried then it's time
to be cautious right and so like we'll
just continue to follow what the data
tells us yep i think you have the
advantage of uh removing the emotion
from it right by looking at these charts
all day which really helps so if you
were to look at timing though uh i think
most people were saying kind of north of
100k by by uh the new year do you think
one that will still get there or do you
think we'll push out a few months into
the into 2022
um i mean
hey i mean i don't i don't think no
disrespect to plan b like playing b is a
really nice guy um and i talked to plan
b i'm like
fairly on the regular but you know if we
if we hit 98k by the end of the year
i'll get a plan b tattoo
i i don't know it's it's hard to say uh
in terms of like
price levels i mean i know i keep saying
that i keep reverting back to the same
thing but i look for the behaviors more
than anything i mean i have some price
models that uh my kind of top model
currently sits at like 125k and that'll
it's based on mean reversion and
realized price which is the cost basis
of investors so like that'll that'll
slope up um if price starts to slope up
because it's partially based on main
reversion uh but for now that sits at
like 125k um
in terms of how fast we get there i mean
who knows i mean it's it's it's hard to
it's hard to kind of make that
conclusion but i do think i do think um
that that there's a there's a strong
chance we kind of extend out into into
the beginning of next year partially
because everybody is expecting us to top
out at the end of this year so in
general i think when everyone's kind of
expecting the same thing the opposite
happens that was also kind of like
illustrated by like this this correction
we had during summer like
everyone thought we were going to be at
like 150 k by by june july uh you know
when everyone's looking at the same
thing i generally kind of think
i generally kind of think that that
doesn't that doesn't happen so like
given that everyone everyone and their
mom thinks that we top out by the end of
december i think there's there's a
strong likelihood we probably extend out
maybe into the first couple months of
next year yeah and i think the thing
with plan b to remember too is he has a
bunch of different models right and
people love one of them because he's
literally giving monthly price targets
and it's like that emotional connection
of seeing the price and saying oh it's
going to get there by the end of this
month and he's been right a few months
in a row or whatever it is uh but his
his base stock to flow model still says
you know 100k average for the for the
having cycles so we'll have to see some
fireworks and there's no time variable
too so that's the other thing people
miss too about the stock to flow model
which i mean i don't i don't watch the
stock to flow model on a day-to-day
basis but you know i do think like
anyone who's like
criticizing plan b just needs to keep
into account that a like the 98 then i
know i'm busting his balls a little bit
a second ago but like the 98 the 98k
price target is based on a his like
unchained floor which i have no idea how
he's calculating that he says it's
proprietary so i have no idea but
the stock to flow model is there's no
time variant to it um and so it's just
you know it it could also mean that we
extend out into next year and reach the
price levels that stock the flow is
saying it doesn't necessarily mean that
we have to reach it by december i think
that's a bit of a misconception around
it yeah exactly i mean he tries to
clarify it i think here and there but
it's never never easy on twitter you
know when you got 1.4 million followers
like
you know you're gonna get some people
that are you know
of course the nuance miss the nuance
there of course i mean yeah i i've been
i've been uh i've been uh kind of
bearing with that as well with some of
this the some of the stuff i put out you
know you really kind of have to not dumb
things down and like because that sounds
like really condescending but you know
you kind of have to like spell things
out for because some people are just new
right i mean yeah you know the people
just get confused because you know not
everyone is is like watching stuff all
day so i mean yeah i i think uh i think
there is a bit of a like kind of
misconception or misunderstanding around
that for sure well i think uh well i
think you're doing just as good of a job
as anyone if not better you're putting
tremendous content out on twitter you do
the newsletter you come on the show you
do a bunch of podcasts and stuff and
you're doing a really good job of
breaking it down so people that are
either new or old can understand it in a
simple way so i think that's great i
highly recommend uh everyone follow you
on twitter everyone knows that's been
watching the show will passed me uh in
the twitter follower account a few weeks
ago uh and he's he's blown by me now but
will's a tremendous follower he's almost
at 420 uh thousand followers now uh he's
proudly displaying that screenshot at
420.69 yeah you gotta try to grab it
hopefully uh i'm sure that'll happen in
the next week or two here hopefully so
make sure to try to grab that one that
happens but uh will where is the link to
your newsletter in your bio is that the
easiest place to go sign up
yeah it's in the bio if anyone's
interested um it's free just you know
you click the link in the bio and sign
up for the email if you don't want to
get emails in your inbox i just post it
on twitter too so you can just click the
link in the tweet every friday the
email's worth it he uh he does the same
charts class note is expensive for an
individual membership so uh will is
breaking it down he's giving you kind of
what you need to know about each chart
and doing a really good job so highly
recommend that will thank you for coming
on we appreciate you man you got
anything good going on this weekend
oh no i'm just chilling uh because
thanksgiving next week i'm gonna just
kind of take it easy lay back keep you
chill but uh yeah thanks thanks joe for
having me on man you're a good host
for his money i appreciate that man i
better watch out man you better watch
out i was telling them yesterday don't
let this get don't let me get too
comfortable up here
yeah you crushed it man and uh yeah i'm
gonna hit you up about the sweater i
want to get one for sure sure i'm sure
dcu will have like some like
ugly sweater parties or something people
people like have all kinds of like weird
themes for parties so i'm sure that'll
be one i'll rock the bitcoin ugly
sweater definitely dude i will send you
the three options you tell me which one
you want we'll send you one all right
all right thanks will all right take it
easy brother